the fact that one human being can say  one thing at the right second to another  human being that can fundamentally  change the process of their life because  they have now decided to open up a  different perspective and see the world  differently is the most intoxicating  most powerful reason that human beings  are the best in the world and i will  continue to be one small version of a  human being one of many millions of  people that are out there who get deep  happiness for themselves out of trying  to be a communicator to help others let  this little rant be the one that says  he's [ __ ] right because if you say  i'm wrong nobody's going to be able to  help you  you're going to be the only person  that's able to help yourself  and if you think  the people that are using fear and  negativity  to get your attention and you're saying  they're right they're just selling you  darkness and you're buying it